Donald Trump's position his opposition
to the clean power plan okay
so Bernie Sanders is up in arms about
that today so is the Democratic Party
saying how could you how could you
possibly be against the clean power plan
because just like how could you be
against choice how could you be against
someone being pro-choice they give they
give these plans or these bills or in
this case a series of regulations these
nice or sometimes benign sounding names
well how could you possibly be against
that I actually will take it one step
further than most Republicans and off I
think they should offer no apologies
completely on board with decimating the
clean power plan but how could you well
I'll explain it but first let's listen
to Bernie Sanders say but how could you
president Trump's anti-environmental
executive orders are disaster they were
a threat to the future of this country
and to the future someone didn't
eagle-eyes their music their todays
energy independence action calls for an
immediate reevaluation of the so-called
clean power plan it is beyond belief
that we have the leader of the most
powerful country on earth not believing
in science oh thanks we'll check that
later mr. science appreciate it okay
we'll be checking all of these numbers
so keep these in mind here here we go
dramatic music sounds like Terminator
17-hundred heart attacks per year
would've been avoided huh where'd you
get those numbers ninety thousand asthma
attacks that sounds good and 3,600
premature deaths getting a little more
general and then their final argument is
despite what the president says
destroying the clean power plan would
not bring back jobs okay so let's unpack
this a little bit right off the bat
wrong simple answer 83,000 jobs in the
coal sector were lost under Barack
Obama's tenure now listen obviously
destroying CPP won't bring back all of
those jobs some of those are permanent
but it certainly would bring back some
of those jobs it would give those jobs a
fighting chance so when you just say
generally I'm gonna save 49 million
premature deaths and uh we're gonna say
no you need to give us specifics so
let's get let's unpack some of these
number
one 2015 regulation alone of the clean
power plan the mercury air and toxic
standards rule let's bring this up has
cost twenty five point six billion
dollars per year now the estimated cost
was nine point six billion this is
important because we'll get to a few
more numbers I never get the decimal
right we're going off of their
projections so we're going off of their
best-case scenario if you go back to
Barack Obama and his projections with
whether it was a stimulus bill doesn't
matter what it was if you go back to
those predictions you will see that it
usually ended up being two to three
times the cost over the course of ten
years cumulative Lee it could be much
more than that the clean power plan has
cost a total of a hundred and twenty
five thousand jobs okay and it's only
really offered a half of the benefits
and the savings that they claim to offer
that's kind of a tricky math because
they can only claim savings once you
remove from the equation fracking and
energy resources that actually would
create savings so I don't wanna get to
that too much but we know concretely
under twenty five thousand jobs are lost
total increased energy costs the US
consumer by the year 2030 with the clean
power plan will be two hundred and
fourteen billion dollars total costs the
overall economy by 2030 will be over two
point five trillion dollars okay this is
by their own estimate so if you read two
point five trillion and probably more
like eighty zillion I'm rounding that's
a good multiplier I'm rounding up how
does all six zeros so we're losing jobs
okay this is so there are concrete
examples we'll get into more but jobs
are being stripped and a big reason the
job loss actually hasn't been worse by
the way is is because of fracking we'll
talk about that's actually been the
biggest boom of private-sector job
growth under Barack Obama despite their
best efforts to completely get rid of it
so what do you think happens here we
keep reducing our ability to use our own
resources okay so take your pick the
Dakota pipeline
take your pick fracking take your pick
clean coal whatever it is if Democrats
had Barack Obama had had his way
offshore drilling if Bernie Sanders had
had their
way all along the trail we would have no
access to our current energy reserves
yeah we wouldn't have enjoyed the
miracle that is fracking that is
unleashed our own resources with a power
that we could have never even possibly
imagined it is probably one of the
greatest modern miracles that I can
think of is fracking so if they had
their way all along the trail
none of these forms of energy would have
been accessible to us okay so not only
we have killed our own jobs not only
will we have reduced our ability to to
use our resources not only we have
increased the costs of energy for
ourselves of course but at this point
reality we still are dependent on fossil
fuels or gas of some sort so we would
still we're not set up yet for wind and
solar across the entire country right
now in the real world 2017 we need to
get our energy from somewhere where do
you think we're gonna get it we're gonna
get it from countries like Saudi Arabia
who couldn't give a rat's ass about
environmental standards
oh you think when they're pulling that
oil they have the EPA overlooking them
no Bernie brings up some statistics
there which are interesting he says that
the the clean power plan would reduce
current power plan carbon emissions by
32 percent ok that's his big claim there
again best-case scenario with his
estimates they reduce it 32 percent okay
let's say we do that that's still less
than 1% of carbon emissions on planet
earth as a matter of fact if you
actually again his best-case scenario if
you eliminated our emissions by 32% and
nobody else in any other country who are
burning literal piles of human [ __ ]
would increase carbon emissions let's
assume that everyone else had a
gentlemen's agreement that we're all
going as lowered us it would it would
keep the average temperature rise
according to their metrics it would keep
that rise it would lower it by point
zero two degrees Celsius by the year
2100 that point two right no point zero
this is best-case scenario assuming with
their with their costs they make some
claims here to that I want to get into
you don't want to get 1,700 heart
attacks 90,000 asthma attacks 36 under
premature death deaths would be and by
the way this is again all over HuffPo
and Vox
they're towering they some people like
oh my gosh that's I can't believe I was
not able to find any actual resources
from this except I think they took it
from the same document from the E
PA that also this reliable document
claims that your tummy troubles are
caused by oh yeah so again this is the
idea where they mock conservatives we
say well listen when you're talking
about climate change funding almost
everything can just be tossed under that
umbrella looks not true it's science and
then literally you'll spend billions of
dollars on a study that says he has
diarrhea because of global warming
terrorists global warming yeah is that
funded by big imodium no it's actually
just haunted by a bill Bernie Sanders
voted for the bill and now we're when
our funding Studies on global warming in
its relation to diarrhea this is just
insane not good enough America so
finally this is something else I find
out she slams Donald Trump Bernie
Sanders slams Donald Trump course for
being anti science big words from an
whose party platform and original home
state believe in 31 gender if only there
was some kind of a crystal ball that we
could look to a beacon of modern clean
energy and what the results were
thanks to our interns Fenn from Germany
who's kind of weird but we like him we
have that information so Germany started
a program in 2010 called
a I don't know how it'll pronounce this
properly energy but vendee energy wind
then the men W is a V okay energy vend
in 2010 bring up the overlay people can
read it so they know what they're
talking about so this is where they
installed a bunch of solar panels
turbines they try to do away with
nuclear energy Germany used a lot of
nuclear energy a lot of its met erect in
Europe nuclear energy has been used much
more than the United States and it's
kind of not a big thing Fukushima and I
got a little gunshot no so turbines or
solar panels here's a problem nor windy
and I will I will openly express my
ignorant here I don't know about you but
I have a lot of friends who use solar
panels on their houses up north and they
charge up a battery than the battery you
know obviously powers a generator and so
they can store solar energy I assumed
that
if we were planning on on making the
bedrock of our future energy policy
solar and wind I assumed that we had the
ability to do that in a large scale it
turns out I was wrong I gave them the
benefit of the doubt like well I guess
solar and wind I was at first I thought
well there's no way that could work and
then I saw a generator that worked in
some pit somebody's tiny house where he
took an old took an old shipping crate
from a freighter and said I'm gonna turn
this into a house with a solar panel I
thought well we can do it there we can
certainly do it on a grand scale for a
country turns out that's not true
everybody back you up ten years before
that where you have to mine this stuff
you should make it yeah
takes a lot of coal energy it takes a
lot of energy to create these solar
panels so there's just no way to sort
this is the reality a lot of people
assume that I did for a period of time
there is no way to store so what did
what happened in Germany well you go
through periods where there's not nearly
enough energy right so everyone has to
conserve it's it's kind of like
California with the droughts there's no
Sun there's no wind you're kind of
screwed and then there were periods
where there would be so much Sun in wind
that they were wasting energy they had a
surplus there power grids couldn't
handle it so they would literally sell
their energy in Germany at a negative
price they were paying you please please
charge your iPad I'm still watching like
every half hour so we had to sell energy
for a negative price and on its worst
day it could cost up to 20 million euros
a day for them to try on any people to
take their energy so you go through
droughts and then you go through these
surpluses that you can't handle and
here's the thing all of this pressure
right and you see the unemployment in
the United States that we would have
from the clean power plan you see the
unemployment that occurred under Barack
Obama and our current energy sectors you
see the actual employment that was
created with fracking and natural gas
and despite Barack Obama's best efforts
the labor participation force rate would
be far far lower if it weren't almost
exclusively for fracking what did we get
in Germany well actually all of this led
to Germany in 2015 increasing
carbon emissions let's recap this okay
we're going to lose hundreds of
thousands of jobs potentially millions
of jobs best projected deficits and
increased spending are in the many many
trillions again probably the tens of
trillions and completely unreliable
energy that cannot be harnessed in times
of drought it will increase our
dependency on foreign oil and foreign
forms of energy period and at the end of
the day if we don't hit our best
possible scenario of decreasing the
average temperature rise over 100 years
by point zero two degrees Celsius we
might actually increase carbon emissions
so yes I say to you zero apologies i
supports not just Donald Trump but
anyone who wants to do away with the
absolute hoax that is the clean power
plan Thank You Germany for screwing up
so that we don't have to like this video
subscribe by clicking the subscribe
button it's Atkinson it's a circle now
it used to be a square which most
buttons aren't squares let's it's on a
phone there's square buttons on phones
what most buttons are circles you
understand what I'm talking about or
watch the recommended video which is
popping up in a box or subscribe at
lateral credit com / menthe club join
the Mudd Club so you can get the daily
show and that means that you are not
beholden to the YouTube censoring
overlords let's be honest you like being
there where you are under their thumb
power bottom you